Lake Las Vegas is what some would call a
Hidden Gem in the far east side of
Henderson currently The Village at Lake
Las Vegas is seeing more Development
Madison Kimbrough spoke to some of the
owners who share how vibrant this area
has become after a long period of
vacancies
seeing more businesses come in different
types of businesses come in and then
seeing the people starting to see it you
know everybody's taking pictures around
here everybody's talking that was Xander
hollom supervisor of The Village at Lake
Las Vegas Harlem sharing with 8 news now
just how much of a development boom he
and others are seeing at the outdoor
shopping venue as three new stores have
already opened this year two of which
are retail stores designer consignment
shop Maiden Lane and clothing boutique
Apricot Lane owners share what drew them
to the area and how business has been
thus far when we found this area we were
so excited we were like oh my gosh this
is a hidden gym I didn't expect to get
the interest
as much interest
into designer Consignment as we're
getting now it was an easy decision to
make when I saw all the new home
development between Cadence which has
almost 5 000 new homes you see all the
development here I thought this would be
a great location and I wanted to get
going before it got you know all the
spaces were taken and we're going to be
full and over at Italian inspired
Breakfast Cafe de Romo the owner's
nephew tells us they are optimistic
about the future of the cafe he cares
really much about this place because it
brings the name of his grandfather and
so his plan is maybe to try to open
different locations so this is the first
one as for other businesses set to open
soon a pet grooming place a furniture
store and a UPS Store are all in the
works
and if you're wondering about montelago
casino that initially opened 20 years
ago according to site officials there
are still no plans for that to reopen